nbc news was even worse nbc news put up
the body cam footage
they took out the part with the knife
and they took out the part from the 911
call
where somebody actually reported that
the girl had a knife in the first place
they just cut it out
the media are rooting for the cops to go
down that is all this is the media are
openly
rooting for this stuff right now here's
the edited here's the edited
clip from nbc news police body cam video
shows micaiah bryant's final moments
when a columbus ohio police officer
responding to a call gets out of his car
and seconds later fatally shoots the 16
year old girl
officer nicholas reardon who joined the
force in december of 2019
was responding to a 9-1-1 call we need a
police officer here now
video shows reardon approaching a group
of young people in this driveway
it wasn't just nbc news cnn there are
growing questions according to wolf
blitzer about what just happened in
columbus
growing well now it seems to me that
once you know what happened there
actually should be
lessening questions should there not
there should be a decrescendo
of questioning considering that we now
know that the cops shot
a black girl who's attempting to stab
another black girl but here's the thing
if the cop had never shown up and makia
bryant had stabbed the other girl to
death
nobody would have cared nobody would
have cared
nobody in the media nobody in black
lives matter not lebron james
not the white house they wouldn't have
given two dams about that girl's life
how do i know
how do i know i know that because it did
happen
okay in cincinnati ohio two days ago a
13 year old girl was stabbed to death
13 year old black girl was stabbed to
death by another 13 year old girl
this is not a national news story
because no one cares if a black person
stabs another black person to death and
they're both 13.
nobody cares if the cop had shown up and
shot
the 13 year old black girl who's
stabbing the other girl then it would be
a national news story about systemic
police racism
here's a story that actually matters
from cincinnati ohio because it turns
out
that the homicide statistics in black
america are
devastating are crippling the number of
black americans killed unarmed by the
police every year is under 20.
the number of black americans who are
killed in homicides every year is
thousands upon thousands
i mean we were talking in the year 2019
alone about 7 500 black americans were
killed in homicides the vast majority of
those people were killed by other black
people because most crime in america is
intra-racial
i mean seriously this true absurdity
that we are supposed to pay attention
only when you when a cop is involved
demonstrates that this is not about
saving black lives not in the slightest
it's about the reverse
it's about we don't care if more black
people get killed so long as we
dismantle the cops it is just anti-cop
hatred
here is this case from cincinnati ain't
nobody going to pay attention to this
because it was just a 13 year old black
a girl whose life mattered also but not
to the media because it wasn't ended by
a cop
i held her i watched it as she died
i watched the hill all i could do was
hold it
devastation heartache loss i tried
i tried to stop the bleeding
are you devastated by that because you
should be devastated by that it turns
out that niara givens which is the name
of the girl who is stabbed
you should say her name much more often
than you say the name of the girl who
was attempting to stab another girl and
got shot by the police
now our givens didn't do anything she
was just stabbed to death but you don't
care about that in the media
that's not national that's a local crime
story it's not a national news story
it's just amazing but don't worry the
questions are growing in columbus not in
cincinnati in columbus here's wolf
blitzer talking about the growing
questions in columbus
we're also following developments in
columbus ohio where there are now
growing questions about the deadly
police shooting
of 16 year old african-american micaiah
bryant
police are releasing more body camera
video that appears to show bryant
wielding a knife
and officers uh warning her several
times to get down before she
seems to lunge at another girl and
police open fire
okay the the grunt growing seams lunge
seems not not lunges
okay and it was across the media it was
just lying about the case just lying
about it
outright pretty incredible msnbc's jason
johnson
he misleads about the case too because
that's what he does
the kia bryant a 16 year old girl in
columbus ohio
called the police for help an officer
was on the scene
and in 22 seconds he shot her dead an
honor roll student
who's making tick-tock videos on makeup
and hair
this hasn't stopped oh it was
yeah just makeup videos that's all she
was doing also attempting to stab
another girl with a knife
but other than that the same the same
the defenses are coming fast and furious
from people of makia bryant's activities
the tick tock things again this is what
the media do they seize on one detail of
a particular case and then claim that
this has something to do with the case
right for trayvon martin it was the the
hoodie and the skittles
and for and for makia brian it's
tick-tock videos
that's irrelevant to why the cop shot
her the captain shooter cause she was
making tick-tock videos he shot her
because she was trying to stab another
girl
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like
and subscribe to help keep our videos on
the front line of the fight and top of
your feed